people constantly like to debate is
bitcoin new digital gold or is gold
still a superior asset if you compare
the two assets bitcoin is superior it's
more portable it's more divisible it's
cheaper to move around the world and it
can be teleported instantly to almost
anyone on the planet that has an
internet connection but of course gold
has been around much much longer than
bitcoin but there's a brand new segment
that max kaiser recently put out that
explains why gold may not be exactly
what you think it is
here is max talking about why gold may
actually be a bet on disaster and
bitcoin is something that's pro-humanity
is paul tudor jones even said that gold
is a bet on disaster bitcoin is a bet on
humanity that it's going to get better
so i mean this is part of this is being
involved in something that's going to
improve humanity improve
um
what our experience as humans you know
on this earth because bitcoin
demonetizes violence
whereas fit fiat money really monetizes
violence you know the the petro dollar
and the whole war industry and it's all
based on fiat money and money printing
and the ponzi scheme of money printing
it's a very violent area of fiat money
is is the source of violence bitcoin is
demonetization of violence so in that
context you're like well you know i'm
doing something i'm part of a bigger
thing and and with bitcoin
everyone who gets involved to it and
with a big in a big way
really learns to get humble and say you
know what this is bigger than me
and there's something is potentially
that could be great for humanity here
now that's a really interesting view of
the world gold is betting on disaster
bitcoin is betting on humanity that is a
black and white view of two different
assets the world obviously isn't black
and white but if you go and you actually
talk to the people who are buying gold
versus the people who are buying bitcoin
you will get two completely different
answers one is trying to protect
themselves from that disaster and the
other believes that there's a peaceful
protest underway that will return the
savings technology to billions of people
around the world that came from sound
money
gold is analog sound money and bitcoin
is digital sound money sound money both
sides they agree is the solution to many
of the macro problems
now the question is will it be the
analog version or will it be the digital
version my bet is on the digital version
but time will tell there's still a lot
of work to do across both communities
and the problems in the legacy financial
system are not going away but i'd rather
bet on humanity than bet on disaster and
my guess is the 150 million plus people
who owned bitcoin around the world
they'd rather do that as well